[MUSIC]
Dream it up.
Dream something bigger than I did.
That's what my grandpa always
told me when I was small.
Grandpa was born in the late 1920s,
when Vietnam was still a French colony.
Life was tough,
starvation was a constant fear.
Growing up, all my grandpa
could dream of was survival.
My father was born just a year before
the French finally left Vietnam.
For the first time,
Vietnamese believed the peace and
independence could be possible.
But then the American came, and
for 21 years of the Vietnam War,
more than 3 million
Vietnamese were killed.
Like grandpa,
my father dreamed of survival.
But this time,
he dreamed of something else as well.
He dreamed of peace.
And then me, I was born when neither
the French nor the American were around.
Food was scarce, but I grew up in peace.
Unlike many others of my generation,
I could afford to dream something else,
something bigger.
I dreamed of a good education.
Three generations,
three very different dreams.
To many people, it is a generational gap.
To me, it is a dream gap.
For most of my life, I've been obsessed
with asking people what their dreams are.
And having asked hundreds if not thousands
of people the exact same question,
I know for a fact that your background
has so much to do with your dreams.
In fact,
your background can dictate your dreams.
In other words, the time you're born,
the place you grow up in,
the family you come from can
determine what your dreams are,
can determine where your
starting point in life is.
Which explains why more than 20 million
today are still at risk of starvation,
still dream of their next
meal every single day.
Which explains why millions of people
in countries such as Syria and
Yemen still dream of peace.
Which also explains why million of
kids still dream of going to school.
So many years have passed,
but at different places,
in different circumstances, millions
of these people still have the same
dreams as three generations of my
family had years ago, the dream gap.
But my talk today is less
about why the dream gap,
but what we can do about it.
I'm going to share with you a story
of a 14 year old boy, Kelvin,
who lives in a slum outside of Nairobi,
whom I met when I was living in Kenya.
Kelvin sold nuts down
the street where I lived.
He got me really curious, because I saw
him sell nuts and take care of his younger
siblings who were always by his side,
and sometimes, big bucks, too.
I always bought nuts from Kelvin.
But one day I asked him the question,
what's your dream, Kelvin?
Dream, I have none.
As a wish, though,
I wish I had enough money to buy food for
my five younger brothers and sisters.
He went on to tell me about his family.
But his father had left him a few
years earlier, his mother was sick.
And at the age of 14 he was
the breadwinner of his family.
It's people like Kelvin that
have taught me again and
again to be curious about
the dreams of people around me.
As different as we seem to be,
I felt connected to him,
because in many ways, he has the same
dream as my grandfather did, survival.
Growing up, I heard the saying, you
are as big as your dream, and I hated it.
In fact, I was afraid that people
would judge me for the dream I had.
But knowing that your background has so
much to do with your dreams, I would never
judge Kelvin, or anyone for that matter,
for how big or how small his dreams are.
It's people like Kelvin that
remind me of the dream gap.
That we come from different places,
we have different dreams, and that's okay.
One day, I asked Kelvin,
have you thought of going to college?
He said,
that is something I really want to do.
You probably call it a dream, but I'm
not sure if I can make it or afford it.
So I tell him about me,
about my dream and how I pursued it.
And I told him that I would
help him pursue his dream too.
So every Sunday at 4 PM I would help
Kellvin sell nuts on the streets
of Nairobi.
100 packs, $0.05 apiece, $5 was what
he needed to feed his family and
to afford to go to school.
And in between, I would teach him math,
his favorite subject.
It's times like this with
Kelvin that made me realize
that knowing somebody's dream is good.
But helping them with that dream, and
helping them build on that dream,
is even better.
And helping isn't necessarily
about giving money, but
it's about giving them support,
giving them a little push.
The day I left Nairobi for
Stanford, it was a Sunday.
I tell Kelvin, it's my last day selling
nuts with you, I'm leaving tomorrow.
He was surprised.
Why are you leaving?
I told him, remember my dream,
good education?
I'm still pursuing it.
I'm pursuing my and
you got to pursue yours too.
You see, the stories of people
like Kelvin or my grandfather or
father, so the stories of dreams
dictated by their background.
But look around, there are so
many Kelvins still out there in the world,
still facing the dream gap.
I hope that with this story, you will
reach out to the Kelvins around you.
You'll be curious about their dreams and
their lives and their stories.
And that you will give them a little
support on their journey to achieve their
dreams.
It's my grandfather that told me to dream
it up which has led me here at Stanford.
Where I found a quote at the G Building,
which says, dedicated to the things
that have not yet happened, and
the people who are about to dream it up.
If there is a place like this for
me, there must be
a place like this for
the Kelvins around all of us too,
thank you
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]